do you want women to be signing up for
selection that's not what i that's not
what i'm asking it's not want i'm saying
do you think that it would do you think
it would be equitable if we said no men
should if men have to if men have to
bear this risk and they and they're
denied these privileges
should should we also force women no
because i don't believe that women are
as capable in that capacity when it
comes to physical strength
when it comes to other components of
what needs to happen physically to be in
the military on the front lines
most times i don't think they're going
to be the best candidate for that job
so
when i talk about military it's not
about woke for me it's not about
this gender and that gender it's not
about it's not about that i want my
military to be as best as it can be
and
honestly if you really took all the
wokeness out of that nine out of 10
times that's going to be a healthy
robust young man should we in some way
devalue women's votes as a result of
that absolutely so what you want is more
authority than men are allowed in the
united states what i want is
for people individuals across the
country men women regardless of race
regardless of ethnicity growth of age
once you hit the eligible age to vote i
want them to have a stake in the game
i want them to
be able to voice
their
you know their policy that's how you
basically should should we then resolve
everything
no
no
well
i mean that's a very complex debate we
could have
should we
should we say you know what it doesn't
matter if you have a dick or a
vagina you don't you can vote there's a
reason that exists though i mean you're
the person who argues all the time that
there are big differences between men
and women yes absolutely 100 so by not
by acknowledging that does my vote count
less than yours because i don't want to
sign up and put my ass on the line to go
die in a way that's like saying that a
guy who doesn't have say you go through
life and you
don't get involved yourself in the
military you don't say you don't have
children say you don't um like you don't
have a voice when it comes to the school
system you don't have a voice when it
comes to things that don't directly
affect your life
you can't itemize it that way every
single person in this country every
single citizen who pays taxes who's here
legally as a legal citizen of this
country every single person is impacted
by the policies that happen in this
country which is why you see people now
moving from state to state i left new
york i wasn't going to stay in that
local hole i came to florida right so
every single individual is invested in a
different way but i can't i can't even i
can't if i'm an illegal alien i can't
become a citizen of the united states
with with a penis anyways to without
signing up for selective services
so that disqualifies me from everything
that you just said right now so i if i
can't if i if i don't if i opt out of
selective services i don't get to be a
us citizen period and that's only
applicable to men not to women yeah but
there's a reason for that because of the
way the military operates that's the one
thing that hasn't gone why doesn't it
apply to then why doesn't it apply to
women then why do like if you're a woman
and you're an illegal alien you don't
have to sign up for for selective
services you can become a naturalized
citizen of the united states and you can
get a full vote before your husband or
your son or whoever else
would ever be able to do that if they
didn't want to sign up for selective
services debate about
that's an interesting debate about so
men have more skin in the game than
women do
men have more skin in the game on that
women
in the game okay that's like saying a
single guy all right
single game as a family living in a
community that has a school district
that's yes but that but that could
potentially be me dying for my country
100
so should my vote count more or your
account or yours count less because that
is a much higher higher stakes game than
what what school is my kid getting you
don't want to you don't want to live in
a country i mean i certainly don't want
to live in a country where we're now
going to look issue by issue and say
that your vote counts more or less based
on your investment that's exactly what
they used to do prior to 1920. that's
why women didn't want the vote i know
but that but see they because they
looked at the they looked at the vote
much differently right right that's one
of the reasons why men resisted for a
long time because men had more skin in
the game but prior to 19.
i don't think that's a now you can have
a conversation about elimination of
selective services that's a whole other
debate that would sit here and have
but
what i think is is beneficial to
acknowledge is that every single person
in this country who pays taxes and who
either who invests in their community
who works who brings home a paycheck who
has a kid in school who lives in a city
that's on fire who every single person
has an investment
in that community and every single
person should have a voice in the
direction unless you're above 18 with a
penis and you don't want to sign up for
selective services because that
disqualifies you from holding well
that's that that's a debate that is
no that is the debate should selective
services be eliminated
as a as a barometer and you said no for
whether or not well you know what i i've
no one's ever asked me that let's be
perfectly honest with you see i would
have to bring the good [ __ ] when i come
in here i would have to really think
about what the implications of that
would be
for
wartime what the implications of that
would be given what's going on with
china so so imminent death imminent
death might change your mind
no but you have to think about it like
we're very privileged right we're going
to invade that's okay we need guys in
selective services now collective
services exist right is there not i mean
they didn't just ha that didn't just you
know oh let's just have selective
services for
by the way they they've that's been on
they've tried to vote that for a while
like i think as far back as like 2015
and it by the way has been conservatives
that have uh negated that like they i
think it was not too long ago they
wanted to put like women into combat
roles or whatever
and so they were opening up certain
branches of the military for like direct
combat roles and trying to get women in
there of course they never pass the
physical but the thing is that they were
very proud of the fact that they got you
know women components out there
that's where i live in that debate you
know i've never had a debate about
selective services that seems like um a
potentially very problematic decision to
eliminate selective services across the
board and it also seems like a
problematic decision to have women
automatically signed up in selective
services for other reasons i agree with
you i don't think women should sign up
for so i don't think that women should
go to the military period end of spring
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]